[Applause]
we're getting back to prostitution
is is legal in new york which is also
going to up the population
probably not maybe it won't maybe it
won't actually yeah those prostitutes
are [ __ ]
barren a bunch of caitlyn jenner [ __ ]
on them prostitutes
[Laughter]
that get his uncle laughs going back
yeah oh good lord yeehaw
[ __ ] hot we got a lot to talk about
boys we got a great pod
and a super special guest that you
probably already know about because he
was in the title and a thumbnail
[Laughter]
um oh [ __ ] okay let's let's
little come together here let's be
serious let's be serious yeah
let's be serious for one [ __ ] second
uh-huh
one second [ __ ] and waldorf [ __ ]
in the waldorf bubbly in the bathtub
tricking on a tall horse something in a
what rhymes with bathtub
why would we pick the hardest words to
rhyme ever why do we do that to
ourselves
[ __ ] in the waldorf bubbly in the
bathtub tricking on a tall horse
in the hat huh let me look up bathtub
brian
got to join the hat club oh that club
could be good gold bottles in the
nightclub huh
how do we do night can't run a club bro
bathtub and nightclub tub and club yo
mark
yo mark you can't rhyme clubbing club
you can buy a tub in club
bath club i thought you said i know
you're saying bathtub not bad clothes
you're saying bath club though
come here bro i'm
[Laughter]
she really is she is he is built like a
pixar [ __ ] bro
you never seen celine dion yeah in the
arms of
an angel sarah you wouldn't know that
you gave [ __ ]
i don't right i was checking to see
which one of y'all
from declining populations if you know
what i mean also
how declining population is it that you
immediately claim celine dion who's from
quebec celine dion
yeah yeah one of the declining
populations
yo celine dion even knowing two songs
about her you can know titanic
bang that's a banger and that's it my
heart will go on
in my heart my heart will go you ain't
never seen power of love the power of
love how does that song go
hi i'm a guy and i take guys in my
restaurant
is that actually a pretty good
impression
was that a quebec accent
yes
[Laughter]
all right let's be serious bro we got a
lot of [ __ ] that we ought to talk about
man
wait he just got rid of his ammo that's
my ammo is done but i got a full one
right here on
deck oh [ __ ] don't act up hey
better not act up
real talk don't act up get smacked up in
a [ __ ] waldorf
yo we got to make a rap song
we did make one like someone made it
yeah but we got to really make it
[ __ ] in the waldorf bubbly in the
bathtub [ __ ] in the wall door bubbly
in a bathtub
tricking on a tall horse and that
[ __ ] ass up
got the bitch's ass up turn them in
[ __ ] in the waldorf bubbly in the
bathtub
chickens on a golf course
that doesn't flow though the flow is
there
golf course what can we do a golf course
um cause that [ __ ] hits a
golf course yeah yeah uh more green than
a golf course
oh more green back more green than a
golf course
you know what i mean what else
clubbing harder than a golf course
clubbing harder than a golf course where
the baby seals that
no come on y'all are crazy right now
y'all are crazy right now
you are nuts you know what i mean
[ __ ] in a waldorf
you are nuts you are nuts fish is in a
waldorf
you know what i mean bubbly in the
bathtub
let's get serious you know clubbing on a
golf course
what yo you are silly
all right come on let's talk about
prostitution in new york let's be
serious yeah yeah we gotta be serious
prostitution in new york is now they're
not gonna prosecute it
i hate that those words are so similar i
know it's yeah so they're not
prosecuting prostitution new york
anymore could this be the worst way to
handle this situation
which situation i'm saying i'm assuming
all these changes are coming from the
fact that the city is broken they need
to make money oh yeah
but if you're not prosecuting it right
maybe you save money on these
prosecutions that the taxpayers have to
pay for but
why don't you legalize it and then tax
these [ __ ]
coochie tax yeah that's a great point
that's how you really make money
right you make it legal now you don't
have to prosecute them save money there
and you tax them
yeah because if you're just gonna make
it not prosecuted you're only gonna
increase pimping
like if you really care about these
women right which they don't but if you
really care about these women
you don't want to increase the pimpin
you want these girls to be able to
support themselves and new york needs
tourists dog
and if prostitution was full ass legal
in new york city yeah but i don't want
to [ __ ] no girl from new york
and should remember puerto rico bro new
york got the point
all right but you don't want you're not
coming you are 50 seconds coming through
yo real talk can we talk about that like
shout out to all the women in new york
but y'all are
gross
[Laughter]
ain't nobody want to hear all that with
your [ __ ] cool vocabulary
dudes don't want to hear all that it was
mad hot outside shut up
shut up with that stop trying to talk
cool women in new york
cut the vocab out slang is for men
not women yo yo yo let's get some sour
diesel this weekend
cheese yo you gotta hit this chocolate
cheese yo if we get some sour diesel we
get that diesel and then we eat a
chopped cheese
that's just gonna be great yo i got mad
heads coming over this weekend oh my god
oh my god i got mad ass coming over this
weekend we're gonna eat chopped cheese
and smoke sour diesel
yo roll that blood i only like
dutchies i only like black a miles of
dust shut up
shut up with it we don't think that's
cute
real talk if a girl speaks with slang
minus two points you don't like a girl
with tim's
say what a girl with tim's no
no i don't have my kids she could wear
those tims i'm not a big fan of girls
wearing tim's but it's not even about
the clothes it's like they stop trying
to be like us
like you're supposed to be girly be
girly don't be like us i know we're cool
you just want to act like us because
we're the [ __ ]
but ladies cut that [ __ ] out have your
own girly slang i love it when girls are
like
i mean the valley girl accent is stupid
but at least it's theirs
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean it's not
appropriated
i'll take slang over the valley girl
actually you're a liar bro
yo i don't wanna i don't wanna who likes
white girls more than you on there i
don't want either but no i don't [ __ ]
with none of the valley girls
so i don't [ __ ] with that valley girl
[ __ ] i just me personal perfect
i look i understand what he's saying
it's annoying the valley girl [ __ ]
but it's not more annoying than if a
girl is trying to talk like a new york
dc yeah
if a girl is trying to talk like a new
york dude that [ __ ] is absolutely
repulsive everybody can shoot the dozens
and then the [ __ ] is fun
yeah if it's the homie it could be the
homie the shorty could be the homie nah
bruh you never had a shorty who's just
the homie
not [ __ ] too no i should have smelled
it no that [ __ ] is broken
that [ __ ] is weird bro yo that [ __ ] was
that dick was fire
you want to go dude i think it was
fireside
beat this [ __ ] up yo yo you beating his
[ __ ] up
right now you want a girl to say that to
you bro like a man after
you really do she don't even put both
her legs over her head just one like
yeah
hit that yo
i'm just saying cut the slang out you
don't think is that are there any people
that find that attractive
i don't know do you find it when
attracting when women talk like men
no do you find attractive when women
talk like men i get sometimes it'll
happen where like i'll meet someone like
a girl for the first time she'll call me
like dude or bro
and i'm like oh yeah off-putting a
little bit yeah
bro like in miami they they do that [ __ ]
a lot bro
hey bro bro but they all got tough
charity
that should be making up for it a little
bit i'd be like yo stop talking like a
dude
yeah i don't know enough girls to talk
with new york slang i'll be honest
because most of the girls i know in new
york are from uh they shipped in
everybody's shipped in transplant very
rare al and i are the only new yorkers
really
yeah there's not a lot y'all are a dying
breed but i would still
say new york women are more
beautiful but miami they take care of
themselves better
yeah because in new york women's just
throwing a [ __ ] hoodie for half the
year but they're
beautiful yeah miami they'd be having
some bust-up faces but the bodies
they get the work done though but miami
win will put in the work new york's got
the most beautiful women in the world
because sp is all the most beautiful
women in the world come to new york yeah
so it's like it's it's not even
every kind of woman maybe l.a could
compare i think the hottest girls in la
that we don't really see when you see
them you're like well what the [ __ ] is
that
yeah you're not even a person yeah yeah
and then new york you just see
hot girls just walking on the street go
speaking of cities with women do you see
charles barkley oh my god
legend bro [ __ ] go say what he said
say what he said so i could enjoy it
yeah
he basically says uh he goes yeah i
think they named him the georgia
bulldogs you know based on the women
they got down
a bunch of bulldogs in georgia bro bunch
of bull that's why there's so many gay
dudes in atlanta probably oh my
god right what
what al how do you say nothing that's
your people bro nah
atlanta don't play july atlanta is the
gayest black sea
population declining in there
declining bro you think red would go
down you know i mean
what in atlanta yeah them gays got more
but they attract more gays who got more
money than gay dudes
that's a good point okay you guys got
the most money you think right of course
yeah they got a lot of money because
they both got to make money because
they're men and then they don't have to
take each other out because they're men
so
it's kind of lit yeah yeah no no kids
win win win
yeah but that's the thing with charles
barkley's comment i'm wondering is it
fair to say a whole city has ugly women
is that
yeah yeah it's hilarious yeah is it is
it it's so funny it's more than fair
it's funny boston
i have been in boston yeah oh yeah san
francisco yeah
yeah no no it's it's really interesting
girls in boston
why is that because um sorry boston but
it's the truth
what what what what what are you what
are you going to say because maybe i was
going to say something different
oh i already said that they're all ugly
all of them are ugly i mean
relatively you think so yeah
that is interesting yeah that is very
interesting
we've sampled a lot of cities that's
true we've traveled all around
are our girls in boston the most ugly
um i don't think they're the most ugly
owl
i think the ugliest is san francisco or
portland
wow nah poland got some sneaky ones no
no no no
no no no no no no no yeah they're
sneaking outside the [ __ ] city where
they sneaking
i mean there's something up over there
there's something up over there portland
is something else
coffee situations that they got going on
what's a little oh yeah
sneaky ones yeah yeah fran icee nothing
yeah san fran is really rough dude
it's really really rough okay you got
any coffee when you was in poland
yeah you didn't get any coffee it's a
coffee situation i don't even know oh i
got the top
i got coffee yeah this guy's declining
bro
yeah i got all the coffee i'm seattle's
best you know what i mean
i'm portland's best
you